and instead you know he will focus and
come back even more determined we never
see Magnus Carlson well I shouldn't say
that we rarely see Magnus Carlson
crumble absolutely and here we go the
game has started yeah and so far early
days but it's a variation of the Queen's
Gambit declined
I'm not accepted
yes so that is all about whether black
captured earlier a Pawn on the C4 square
but he declined to take that pawn and
now by trading off here okay we're going
to the tarash defense
uh this is maybe a bit rare nowadays at
the top level uh black taking that pawn
there is something they call the uh what
is it yeah they do both yeah I think I
mean again chess will of course but
there's a the do both
um tarash I think which is some line of
this I'm not too too uh aware of it
because I I noticed it on Twitter
someone was saying how interesting is
from the black side and uh obviously
Magnus has worked with dub offers a
second so maybe that's what he's trying
to do and historically this opening for
black side was played uh by spaski
Kasparov in some big world championship
matches and it was like a way it was a
way where black gets a worse Pawn
structure but he gets better activities
for his pieces so it is definitely a way
to play brisky chess for a win because
you are maybe giving yourself a bad Pawn
in the middle but your pieces are very
free so that that shows magnus's uh
intention I think in this game last move
seems a bit rare to me it seems a little
bit odd I mean it's not I don't know
don't know the opening very well but it
seems a bit peculiar but again some
another peculiar thing is that Magnus
Carlson has actually played this with
the white pieces against Jordan van
forest in the chasseball Masters and
they're Magnus won so it seems like the
two are kind of using some kind of
reverse psychology against each other
in your opponent's weapons against them
that's interesting yeah sometimes it's
good as you mentioned good psychology it
makes them Wonder have they studied my
games before
if levon's playing this against Magnus
has he studied Magnus doing this on the
white side
he stopped level of Iranian much earlier
than he did in the previous game okay he
trades off for the Black Knight and he
really opens things up aggression early
aggression I mean I like I like the look
at this from the white side because uh
you're trying to use your slightly
better development uh by opening the
position and um you can see White's got
two minor pieces developed two Knights
versus blacks one bishop and also
White's Bishop is ready to come with a
check looks very scary for black so it's
kind of position that you need to have
done your homework in uh which I'm sure
Magnus has just the speed that he's
moving here a couple of options though
night now you know in this position the
Knight centralizing looks good but as
there's other moves to consider as well
yeah you could take the pawn hit the
queen he also hit the spawn makes a lot
of sense you mentioned other move Simon
I guess throwing in this check it's not
clear when you should do it you can do
it now or on the next few moves
and uh this is also a bit awkward for
black to answer if you throw the knight
in the way I think this is probably the
most logical move but later you have to
be careful of some Pawn stepping forward
with a with a double attack
at the moment though this horsey this
night is attacked as well it gets really
complicated very complicated this is why
you muster your homework in such sharp
lines Enlighten us Ivanka we haven't
done our homework so uh tell us what is
the most common in this position well
both moves are equally viable and this
one is has been played before
um the top game there is actually by par
Iranian Grandmaster para maxoodlu and
that game ended with maxillou losing
with the white pieces
and after this move the bishop coming to
check is the most popular move and then
the Knight blocks and then the queen
comes in to defend the Knight and
mess basically there's a lot of
imbalances I mean I'm worried about this
King yeah if I was uh black in this
position I definitely don't think it
wants to go Queen side it's too open on
that flank
yeah they tend they tend well when this
came it did go to the left wow how open
is this though yeah but I mean the
situation got kind of messy but I mean
there were previous lines where they
went to the right okay instead Levon
okay this decision looks a bit odd
yes he grabs a pawn but he allows this
bishop to develop uh with Tempo I'm
assuming Magnus will capture this Knight
and uh after the Knight is traded off at
least now it's much much quicker for
black to Castle so you've kind of helped
your opponent speed up their development
white is temporarily a pawn up okay
Magnus does go for this trade I'm not
sure whether you Castle first you could
go for a check uh hitting the white king
and then just win your Pawn back if you
want to play safe
I think Levon aronian because he won the
last game he just wants to get to Safety
in this one
he knows that he's been out prepared
just like Magnus was out prepared in the
previous game now he has been surprised
by the opening with white and he doesn't
want to take risks because if you look
at the position uh here for example
look at the pawn structure completely
symmetrical look at the pieces identical
it's just level and I think he wants to
go for the draw I totally agree I think
you know that that extra half point just
gets you one step closer uh to beating
the world champion so you bought why
take any risks and you know in a
variation your opponent's clearly
prepared makes a lot of sense to bail
out here
even so definitely well that would be
good news for Magnus Carlsen with the
black pieces if he does get a draw in
this game two more games to get that win
but it is very dramatic right now for
Hans Neiman he lost the first game and
in game two against Liam he bars all the
way over to Liam's side is Hans losing
another one
Hans has been out prepared Liam just on
fire in the openings in both games Liam
was winning with black the the previous
game after 10 moves now he's winning
with white after 15-20 moves uh looks
like just unfortunately getting caught
in the opening there Hans Neiman okay
yeah and uh whilst the players are
having a think you know I have a few
questions from our viewers the first one
is from Luke Walsh who asks us what is
each commentator's one bold prediction
about the outcome of the generation cup
production bold production yeah David
glad you asked David because I don't
even know what the generation what's the
generation cup
well there you go I thought I thought I
was doing a job somewhere
I don't I don't need to know I can say
it's the Julius bear you know the
sponsors but I didn't realize the Julius
generation cup try not to go in red now
where am I what what am I doing there
I'll just see you later here cheers bye
sure I thought it was another
competition coming up
okay David over to you sir
I'm not sure whether it's bold at this
point but I'll say a teenager is going
to win the tournament oh nice one I've
got five and eight chance
happened here wait really wow and okay
um so the computer we see the top stock
fish moves it confirms black has a
winning move it's not King C8 which the
computer says it means Castle in
queenside so the black king is going the
cast of Queen side we said it was too
risky earlier but now it just wins has
he forgotten this is legal I'm trying to
work out why as well Kaya I guess it
just creates a deadly pin and if we jump
into the game right now uh we have to
investigate actually there's two strong
moves even giving a check with the queen
which is also natural that gives black
an advantage a castle and queen side
wins on the spot
it is quite natural what do you think
Simon yeah yeah I mean that well it is
very natural The Rook The Rook comes
into play uh it pins the bishop you get
the other Rook ready to come in as well
that might be a key thing I mean it
looks so obvious uh to to play this move
and uh I was Magnus gonna play it I mean
I think he spotted it 100 I reckon 100 I
think he's seen that for sure definitely
he's looking at and uh well I mean it's
such an obvious move did you reckon Lev
forgot that uh so I think so because
somehow other you know it wasn't
possible and he plays it and uh it's
looking yeah very bad take a look now
will he realize because why on Earth did
he then move his Bishop if it was that
bad exactly yeah it was actually before
he moved his Bishop let's just backtrack
two moose before he moved his Bishop
Castle in queenside again was illegal
the White Queen covers the d8 square so
you would be castling through check and
that's not possible so if you just move
this bishop one square for example the
game goes on it's fine but now the
reason as well that this is so strong
casting Queen side he just creates a pin
you pin and you win and if white cast
was kingside now then I guess the idea
there's several ideas here but one of
the ideas is to just try and win this
bishop this bishop cannot move because
it is pinned the black Rook would then
uh capture the White Queen and if you
can't move your Bishop
step back and defend I guess but at the
very least you just trade off and you
move your queen and whoops this Knight
again is pinned and it's just lost you
lose a piece for free
and uh if you don't castle if we go back
to the current position on the board if
you don't cast your king as Simon
mentioned it's just coming under Fire
and there's all sorts of checks there's
a check from this angle there's a
incoming check if the black Rook moves
into the center soon
um when do you even move your queen to
break this pin on the defile and you
know we're safe no there's definitely no
way surf the only place that I can see
that is like remotely viable is to put
the queen on the B1 square but I'm like
cringing inside I'm thinking oh yeah I
mean just White's King is so weak right
I mean exactly you've got so many
tempting moves uh after that one I mean
it's yeah I mean and I think it's
complete I mean you can even attack the
Knight of your Bishop can't you and just
you know there's so many winning moves
here
um uh I and it's actually very simple to
play yeah I this is the problem we're
playing so quickly right I mean uh Lev
Lev has banged out his moves uh again in
a position without too much thought he
has castled here
um you were just showing the Slime David
I I don't think that's gonna say the
pieces it doesn't look too difficult as
well it's kind of which piece is pinned
is this bishop so just come and attack
it that just wins immediately maybe the
stronger moves I mean maybe you could
attack it with your Bishop as well uh
for example like this or
I don't know there must be yeah a bunch
of moves you can play right now but uh
maybe like you said you can go this way
with the bishop everything's just
falling apart yeah it's horrible I mean
you know yeah with correct play Magnus
we'll win this one and that that will
level score just one bad move it just
shows you you've got to in chess it's
such an unforgiving game you've got to
keep your concentration all the time if
you just have you know if your brain
drifts and you like think where am I
what's normal I'm accommodating on for a
second it all goes wrong you've got to
know where you are at all moments
and I am in the studio really I hear it
hello so just remember that yeah don't
don't let your guard down at any any
moment you know yeah otherwise it'll
you'll pay the price you're paying the
price and uh just want to share with you
one picture that I will selfie from
Scott B Robinson
um if you guys will indulge me they are
sporting they're caracon t-shirt just
for me who will play it today you have
that is the question Scott who will play
my favorite opening now I can actually I
don't know whether I've said it before
but I actually have
not that t-shirt but I have got the
hoodie version of that
I feel like we don't see the corocon I I
you know I wouldn't recognize it but I
don't hear you guys saying oh it's a
caracon uh in the multiple Champions not
not this tournament yeah not this
tournament yeah I've barely remember any
but it goes in and out of fashion just
like most openings I mean there's kind
of the the staple diet of NHS player is
Queen's Gambit and the Sicilian and
maybe the Spanish opening for example
those three you'll always see but there
are others like the French defense the
Kara Khan Scandinavian they kind of they
orbit each other one month you'll see
loads and then you might not see them
again for two three months uh-huh but uh
yeah I mean all of the top players at
some point have experimented with most
of these openings it's just
it's just following fashion yeah
definitely and thank you Scott for
making me smile
and uh of that us caracan fans have to
stick together of course caracon
appreciation Club especially after we
were maligned by Benny in that in the
was it the Queen's Gambit he was a
strange chap though wasn't he I mean it
was a bit strange he carried his knife
around everywhere didn't he remember
that he had his little like yeah what's
that all about you know is that not
maybe it's just normal in America or
anything it's pretty cool
Dave Quirk you just want to get you a
little knife Rockstar the cowboy hat
yeah yeah that's the same actor who
played in Love Actually yeah that's what
the kids I love actually yeah and
someone told me that I was like oh wow
and Game of Thrones oh yeah yeah and uh
meanwhile black has won a piece Magnus
is winning this position the White Queen
has gone on a little Adventure she's won
a pawn in the process
looks like she can give one check to the
black king but the black king will just
move very safely and
the problem is white has no backup white
has no second attacking piece yeah it
kind of looks scary the black king
doesn't it I mean it looks a bit exposed
but you can't really damage your
opponent's king really just with one
piece you know you've only got the queen
there and there's there's not much going
on but blacks pieces he's got four
pieces in the middle of the board all
ready to attack and one of them is an
extra piece so uh is is yeah it could
just be and I think over very shortly
this one and I just wanted to point out
that the black queen is is both an
attacker and a Defender if the worst
comes to the worst you know if White
Queen gives a check you can just block
it with your queen and say what you
doing yeah
true the black queen does a great
defensive job actually stopping all the
tracks you could also we should mention
just move the black king it's fine this
is only one attacking piece well I can
give another check but then the king
will hide and uh yeah once that little
excitement has died down Iranian will
count and he'll count that he is simply
losing Black's Bishop is actually it's
not just any Bishop it's a monster as
you guys pointed out this is actually a
killer threat as well Bishop takes
Knight ruining the white Pawn structure
uh with that in mind the White Knight
had to run away and it stepped back
but now I mean if you want you could
trade off the knights you don't have to
it feels like the white king is actually
in more danger than the black king just
because there's more pieces around it
but how does Magnus deliver The Knockout
blow I'll just see
the coup de gras as they say
yeah the killer touch looks like there
should be something really nasty here
just with uh the black pieces quite
quite nicely positioned there
um but I can't see an absolute killer I
mean you can play nearly any move and
win this at the moment
um but obviously you have to be careful
but is there a killer move though I
would be tempted to just laugh at this
Knight and Retreat to just say haha you
put your knight on a bad Square your
Rooks are not connected this Rook can't
move
I am just perfectly centralized I think
when in doubt just centralize your
pieces
that's a good move as you guys said I
mean you can do pretty much anything in
this position you can just trade off
Knights you can just yeah maybe just
move your Bishop out the way and protect
your knight like this maybe line up your
queen against that soft Square you know
just put the queen in the middle and
move it move the queen one square left
or right and that also ties White's
Knight down really there's no threats to
Black's King you've got a couple of
checks and it ends there's nothing you
can do to Black's King here as long as
you're careful about that and this also
creates a threat and Knight takes Knight
winning the game this might be this
might be a looks great Simon looks yeah
excuse it I mean maybe we'll see a
Checkmate on this square at the end of
the game uh yeah to finish things off
but Magnus he's doing the right thing
again he's done hard work one a piece
and okay he retreats
and uh good move
yes so tell me great minds great minds
he's just trying to think you know how
do you really kick kind of put the boot
in kick your opponent while they're down
could be a massive round of comebacks
miners who lost in the first round to
Lavon now with the black pieces it looks
like he's gonna win this one and uh
pragma Nanda he also lost the first game
with the black pieces now with the white
pieces I think the bar is uh slightly to
his side against Vincent kymer and Liam
Hans Neiman game two Hans as well lost
with the white pieces in game one and it
looks like he was losing this as well
but now the bar has completely shifted
to his side is he now winning has there
been a blunder by Liam
um no one blunder but Liam I think made
a series of small mistakes he actually
had a winning attack he didn't go for
the attack and then that's the problem
with chess as soon as you stop attacking
you lose momentum and things do turn so
uh great defense from Hans and he's now
a big favorite
opportunity there for Leanne could be a
comeback then by Hans Neiman here in
round two in the quarterfinal matches
um Christopher you he also lost first
game now playing with the white pieces
against Sergeant Eric icy that game
started not too long ago when the bar is
roughly in the middle
but maybe he will be inspired by The
Comebacks Crystal for you
yeah definitely and uh well we were kind
of I had a few more questions to ask
okay
towards Simon
you know what I honestly don't know
guys yeah throwback Thursday okay
Thursday yeah I was going to say
Wednesday so yeah okay well well I'm not
sure now
um but uh Spruce asks us it often seems
like you can find good moves way easier
in other games than in your own and any
tips for improving your view of the
board
um I mean you can try different things
out depends if you're playing online or
actually in a tournament and uh one one
person who's coached me at an event said
to get your opponent's point of view
actually if you stand up and you go and
look around from the other side of the
board so you're always looking at from
your own point of view maybe if you're a
really optimistic player you're looking
at like from the white side but there's
a lot of moves in the game but I don't
think much has really happened but if
you just stand up and walk around so
suddenly you're looking at the board
from your opponent's view you can get a
different kind of perspective on what's
going on so that's something you could
try I I don't do that myself I tried it
and just found it really annoying but
you might want to give it a go um any
other little tips David yeah I mean a
few things I agree just getting up
whether you look at it from your
opponent's point of view or not
sometimes if you get up kind of Splash
water on your face have a snack have a
drink then come back
you see things differently or you see
something that wasn't previously there
just take your mind off the board for a
couple of seconds
a couple of minutes another thing that
I've learned from commentating uh
previously my mind was just a jumble it
was just variation variation variation
it still is sometimes but I like to kind
of take a step back and just think okay
what would I do if I was commentating on
this position and actually that gives me
another perspective I feel that's helped
my kind of longer chest my classical
chess just breaking Getting Back to
Basics is often a nice nice way to do it
calculation is good but not just moves
in the head sometimes words are
necessary to kind of with decision
making uh yeah that process interesting
so good advice from our Grandmasters I
would also add one little thing which is
sometimes it's good to take the emotion
out of it because may you maybe you've
been winning and you're not winning
anymore life happens
that's what that's what occurs and you
should just as these twos have said just
get up take a walk and just reset and
just do what needs to be done and just
have that Mantra in your mind
yeah I mean if it's a long game if it's
a two three hour game you can't
concentrate nobody can concentrate the
whole time so you need to make sure you
take breaks in Rapid chess you want to
concentrate most of the time but uh you
need to pace yourself
meanwhile black is two pieces up on the
board yeah it's funny one piece got
pinned on the D3 square and black one a
piece as we saw earlier then a second
got piece got pinned on the exact same
square so level of running he's lost a
bishop and a knight on the exact same
square
uh I would say you know he's fallen for
the same thing twice but he was already
losing so he had to try something and at
least now he's pushing some pawns
towards the black king he's doing
exactly the right thing I mean like when
you're losing when you've actually lost
a piece or let's say even a pawn uh the
best thing to do is try to make the
position completely murky you know you
want to make it as confusing as
complicated with no fear because you're
going to lose if you don't anyway so you
might as well try to confuse your
opponent just by as he's doing here
pushing pawns towards his pawns King you
know if Magnus gets confused he he could
get in trouble now because there's more
more things coming towards that King so
that's kind of fun yeah sometimes nice
to be losing like you know maybe losing
in life as well you've got less to worry
about right you can just be like yeah I
don't care anymore just get on with it
you know you know so it's yeah you've
got more freedom haven't you I suppose
in some ways to to risk it take more
risks I call it blagger mode aha have
you heard of that word is that no it's a
British thing I think blagger is Swindle
yes is the British thing isn't it yeah
you know just basically means like these
guys say you know you're not objectively
you're lost but you're just winging it
you're just freestyling and you know
okay fine enjoy it and uh Magnus doing
great things because when your king is
in trouble we've always said time and
time again try and stop off Queens yeah
that being said he is giving a piece
back so the bishop in the center of the
board can be captured by White's Rook
I I was expecting Magnus to somehow give
up his Queen in that position I don't
know why that would just have been a
Magnus thing to do uh give up his Queen
maybe for white to rook and he would
have still been winning uh black has so
many pieces but yeah as Ivanka says this
is very logical very safe
and okay The Rook hat has captured the
black Bishop Magnus doesn't look happy
and okay he takes the Queens off the
board the risk is removed
but maybe not as winning as he was it's
only a night for two pawns now still
winning of course still winning I mean I
kind of like what he's I mean if he can
just uh negotiate this little bit of
Mayhem that's happening here there is
still a bit of Mayhem Lev's doing a
great job of uh just cruising like
Mayhem then obviously the piece will win
the game and it's often a good idea to
give back material to to get you know
calm down your opponent's initiative and
how can Lev do anything here to to
confuse Magnus and he's got okay
he's got this move I like that move so
you don't get pinned and you just gotta
mop up those pawns slowly and I think it
looks pretty pretty easy now to be
honest so yeah the evaluation bomb might
have gone down but it's still completely
winning and now for a human at least
it's easier to navigate so uh just a
very good technique now the problem is
if black can bully white with the threat
of Rook exchanges black still still has
the extra Knight the white pawns will
drop off later
I like this yeah last move as you say
Simon that white porn is like a double
agent it's actually helping black to
protect his King why didn't he just uh
take the pawn what am I not seeing I
think that was a good move as well Kaya
um but he wants to keep the black king
as safe as possible and this white Pawn
is not running away anytime soon so
maybe he'll even use the black rook and
go and capture that pawn and the black
king is entirely safe from the white
Rook uh or the white two white Rooks
that was the only hope for Levon so
fiend Cheto or fianchetto Rook you know
it's a very good piece you know if you
can get that in front of your king and
well okay magda's just centralizing at
the moment
I mean you can play this on a bit but I
mean you know what I do here clearly I'd
have done it a long time ago just
resigned yeah so just tracling yeah I
might get a t-shirt just just resigned
just I'll do that when I'm you know for
maybe somewhere else you know I I think
you know now that this has become
Simon's catchphrase amongst other things
you know we should kind of immortalize
it in the chess 24 Play Zone and every
time you hit resign just resign just
resign yeah you know Simon comes up well
done you've resigned yeah people will be
so annoyed you know because it's
horrible to resign anyway and if you've
got my face coming up and no that's not
good it's not a good idea or maybe if
you're playing and then you ask the
computer for tips and the computer's
like yeah you're done
but I like the idea of having a t-shirt
that just says it's time to resign and
like you have your jumper on yeah you're
playing someone and as the position gets
pretty good you're like you just take
the jumper off and it just says time to
resolve oh I like it I like that yeah I
like that I'm gonna yeah so sadistic
yeah just resign now I mean Kasparov I
think used to do a similar thing he used
to take his watch off uh during the game
and he put his watch next to his board
so that his watch there but then when he
when he was winning and when he expected
his opponent to resign he'd just get his
watch and he'd make a big thing and put
it back on his wrist now basically
saying it's time to go now so whenever
he put his watch back on you knew you
might as well just
resigning little strategy see have you
had a have you ever had any opponents do
that to you like tell me to resign or
tell you to resign but make it clear
that they were expecting you to resign
and they did not want to be playing this
game I've met a lot of strange people in
the Chess World
um definitely I can't remember any
who've made it clear you know they're
like you know like this kind of thing
but um I don't know I probably have done
though I would have thought so yeah I
don't know when I played Magnus in the
London classic 2010 I think
um so he dealt played me he had a
winning position my king was in the
middle of the board about to get
checkmated and he was just kind of
sitting there like like okay and then he
played it one last move and then I
resigned instantly I didn't even look at
what the move was and only after the
game did I realize that he'd blundered
and I I wasn't kind of drawing or
anything again I was still kind of worse
but I was no longer losing and I could
have fought on like given some serious
uh fighting chances so it was just the
body language I just given up mentally
and uh I mean that's no fault of his he
didn't realize it was a kind of a
mistake either but yeah I shouldn't have
trusted the opponent oh that's why
you've got to focus on the board
absolutely and uh yeah meanwhile black
has done a good job of trading one set
of Rooks off all he needs to do is trade
off the remaining set of Rooks and
Black's extra Knight will tell ah must
be so annoying for 11 getting a win
against the world champion Magnus in the
first game that is not an easy thing to
do but then coming in game two white
pieces oh and it looks like it's going
to be a loss he has to start from
scratch two games to go in the rapid
portion to win the match
that's a black day in this matchup at
least also the matchup between Liam Lee
and Hans Neiman it looks like a day to
be black like winning uh all of the
games in those matches so far
and okay White's Rook he's doing what he
can Levon he's trying to bring his Rook
across if you can eliminate all of the
black Pawns it's gonna be a draw from
his Magnus won't allow him to do that
he's making it kind of tricky though
isn't he I mean he's he's uh being very
resilient here uh you know and I suppose
yeah you might as well just play on he's
played very well since blundering his
piece on move 12 he has yeah yeah since
then he's played just to keep the game
going it has been very impressive
um you know that's where chess is
different from other sports you can make
one mistake early on in other any other
Sport and any fight back chess you lose
a piece on move 12 you play Perfect
chess and you still lose yeah some
mistakes you can't come back from just
like to say thank you for Kevin for for
purchasing that book the black line one
of my one of my latest chess books and
it was actually Kevin who told me about
the opening in the first place see he
was telling me about this opening that
you play as black and I was like I was
ignoring him for a while like you know
it's just rubbish and then he he was
being persistent and I thought I better
look at this I like Kevin I had to look
at her oh hello this is quite
interesting you know and then I started
to play it so yeah
funny how you find openings like that so
yeah yeah we mentioned it recently good
opening actually yeah what tricky it's
good at Club players or did Kevin
Costner there was a book already written
by two Dutch authors and they did a book
they called it the black line it was
nothing to do with me they did a great
book they were The Originators I just
try to advance the theory a little bit
to the Modern Age so I can't I can't
remember there are precise names maybe
someone in the chat can help out there
but yeah it's a cool name as well you
know so
um is there such such a thing as a black
life there's not there's not no it's
actually a mythical thing yeah I thought
there was a black line because there are
pictures on the internet but they're all
fake so I did actually I have actually
done my research because I I have said
in the past any opening named after an
animal is is rubbish yeah but the black
line is not an animal it's a mythical
creature so it's okay so that's how I
get out of it so yeah I'm gonna go and
invent the Unicorn opening next time I
have a hippo then
so
the hippos are good okay yeah these two
uh yeah they're obliged to say it's good
it's as good as the Carrow
[Music]
I mean it's a very easy and nice opening
to play so it's got a lot of positives
like any opening does really uh I think
you there's a lot of argument isn't
there I mean black is still winning this
one by the way just have a look at the
position uh he's got to be careful he
doesn't lose too many pawns but he's got
enough and uh he'd be winning another
one very shortly so it's just a matter
of time but uh there's so many arguments
I see sort of online about that openings
rubbish and players who say that are
generally quite low rated they say you
can't play that opening it's rubbish and
it doesn't matter that much you know
most openings are playable this is what
you've got to remember it's the middle
game that lets down most you know 99 of
players so don't overthink the opening
too much just get a position you can
play is just a key bit of advice until
you get to a really strong level the
openings become much more important the
higher up you are I feel you know
um so is Magna still cruising here I
think so he's just one upon the Black
Knight cannot be captured because it's
discovered check the black Rook suddenly
attacking the white king so the white
King has to move and your right Simon is
no matter what the opening as long as
you're familiar with the middle game
plans the murder game maybe Pawn
structures uh that's enough that's
enough and work on those end games and
Lavon had to step the king down that was
the only way he could maintain his
threat against the F7 Pawn otherwise the
Knight would have given a check
oh no not not a check but trying to
check yeah um maybe we can just show
this on the board
it was a winning check from black uh the
Knight attacking the king and the pawn
the king tried to defend the pawn and
discover check as we mentioned throwing
the Knight out the way hitting the king
and Ivanka mentions that okay this way
would be a clear night fork and uh the
other way would also walk into uh
obscure right yeah the night coming in
and if you take this Pawn then okay
another night Fork then I could come
along or you could skewer the white king
and Rook there's all sorts of Tricks
because black has two pieces white only
has one and if we catch up with the game
position we might be seeing Levon
aronian resign any second this is a
check and when the king moves the Black
Knight is going to go park itself in the
middle of the board defending this Pawn
which defends the spawn which defends
the spawn and uh you cannot get rid of
this formation Magnus is simply winning
he can defend his Knight with his Rook
when he wants this Pawn will drop and uh
it's game over too much material
okay I live on trying one final trick
the king moves now black can just defend
his Knight with his Rook
I suppose you can attack you can move
the Knight if you really want to be
flash but this is safe yeah just get the
get the Box on and this is flashy Simon
attacking The Rook or it takes pawn and
another skewer check and you win The
Rook but uh yeah Magnus just doing it
the uh the simple way
Avon just keeping the spawn alive but
it's going nowhere
you can see how it's determined level
one is today though obviously the way
he's playing
um he's he's really this is a good sign
for him you know after him struggling a
bit in the qualifiers is going to be
equal after this game I think unless
something tremendously strange happens
to Magnus yeah I yeah with five minutes
on the clock yeah I haven't ever seen
Magnus through something like this not
since he was like five years old or
something even then he was probably
losing the pram yeah yeah throwing Rooks
out the door here you go have a rook so
that extra Black Knight is it's found
loads of uh kind of safe squares
outposts and that's the key if you can
keep it on a safe Square you will win I
think the Rooks kind of come and take
that last Pawn now it's it's one simple
there's many many ways you can win this
but okay Lev's trying but you can take
that white porn now yep bring the black
Rook back if you want to play safe you
give a check first yeah maybe the king
can snake its way to the right stale
mate stale Matrix if you take the pawn
oh
that's true
have a Checkmate the white king trapped
yeah nice check mate oh we rarely see
that in chess this is a comeback bye
Magnus Carlsen the vulneronian he uh
loses game two and that means they are
tied after two games with two rapid
games to play and uh Checkmate on the
board what happened in this game one bad
decision